hello guys it's Greg the elbe inator
Danny do you baby Danny T baby is back
that's right the beautiful Danielle is
here and colorful now that I'm single
yeah hot sexy Oh
closest intimacy I've had in a while
we're gonna check out from top five
unknowns five heroic moments in
frightening situations from top five
unknowns they're a great channel and I
support whatever they do no matter how
dark but this is like heroes okay and I
consider myself a hero I do as well
like you consider me a hero yes III
really am but you are a humor hero I
have saved a cat out of a tree my cat I
have stopped the woman from being
abducted and I have killed three corrupt
police officers and I set a theater on
fire once during the screening of
Passion of the Christ I'm also a bad boy
okay good
definitely superhero though there's a
fifth one especially the new look yeah
definitely the superhero love don't I
rip your shirt open and unveil
so how about heroes like most of us
think that heroes have capes and
superpowers and devote their lives to
save us but those heroes are just the
ones in the comic books and movies the
heroes in our world can be a random
bystander who intervenes in a dangerous
situation from stopping robberies and
saving lives welcome to five heroic
actions caught on tape I've locked all
my heroic experience number five it was
regular day at work for Missouri science
teacher Betsy their first teaching
previous class as she always did but on
that day she heard some weird sounds
coming from outside the classroom in
fact they were so strange that she went
to check it out this is when she saw a
student gage Donna choking or what
seemed to be a piece of candy very
immediately reacted and went to perform
abdominal thrusts on piece she reacted
in just the right time and managed to
save gages life number 4 defer this next
video takes place in China when two
robbers decided to steal an elderly
woman's purse the robbers got into a
moped so that they can get away faster
the unknown hero in this video saw this
happening and thought up of a quick way
to stop the robbers his method was to
throw his bike at the robbers so that it
would fall off the moped no the bike the
man distracted the robbers until hotel
security could come restrain and arrest
them did he use Jackie Chan this next
case seems like it was pulled right off
from an action movie it took place on a
highway in Nebraska when a cargo truck
driver suffered from a seizure at the
wheel luckily for this driver a deputy
saw him having the seizure and was
determined to help them the deputy
jumped from his car into the cargo truck
to see no was successful in stopping the
truck saving countless lives including
the driver sweet it's pretty cool it was
just a normal day for Katy Nelson who
was just having lunch and enjoying her
time when suddenly out of nowhere a
speeding car crashed into the Portland
Harbor she didn't have to think twice
before jumping into the water climbing
up to the car to see if there was
survivors in the car still in shock she
noticed a figure in the car that's when
she noticed an 84 year old who was later
identified as Ursula Nixon who's trapped
in a sinking car perhaps the woman's arm
pulling her out of the car and saving
her from drowning this heroic action was
filmed by observers who witnessed this
event unfold I would do that number one
a young mother identified as Amy caller
was shopping at a local store with her
two-year-old daughter when suddenly her
daughter lost consciousness and stopped
breathing the terrified look and mother
rapidly brought her unconscious daughter
to the checkout counter for help
shoppers nearby can be seen trying to
revive the child as the mother ran out
to alarm the father of what was going on
inside the father can be seen breaking
down seeing his lifeless daughter on the
counter the situation seemed like a
never-ending nightmare as many attempted
to revive the child but failed a man
identified as rolling O'Neal made one
last attempt by performing CPR on the
young girl at that moment her eyes
slowly opened and she was breathing
again Wow
thank you so much for watching video if
you enjoyed it a big thumbs up and don't
forget to click that subscribe button
for more updates two of those five
things that happened I think about on a
daily basis and have a fear of which
ones are those choking on food I eat so
quickly and so much and I don't chew so
I'm always like oh my god I'm this just
you know and then having a seizure while
I'm driving even though I don't have
seizures I'm still like I'd love to make
you choke on something that would cause
seizures
oh yeah we'll take some ecstasy - to
enhance them
no no y'all sweaty clammy or sticky
bodies just stuck together
I like being sticky with you I never
said it was good no the first one was
cool I mean it was a weird setup because
I thought like oh these are little
things they did but you know she saved
that kid from choking on are you on Iman
top are you yawning while I'm talking
you don't even try to cover your mouth
in a polite way
mm-hmm the Heimlich maneuver is
something I'm very good at oh yeah I'm
very good at it I feel like I should
learn can one do the Heimlich on
themselves
um I don't think so because it takes
like a certain motion where you have to
like from them from here and then you
get like pool so what do I do
if I choke I'll just punch yourself in
the stomach
helps me choke once a day on the-- the
Jackie Chan throwing the that was
awesome
that was like if you watch her that guy
did he he just went up with he wasn't
like look I gotta run just walk they're
[ __ ] through it and then after they
fell he just walked in like a badass way
towards them - yeah I wish I could do
that I feel like I feel like I could I
wouldn't tackle them
oh what a matter thing I would have
tackled them and and put put myself in
them they were on to establish dominance
okay but first you've to get them off
the motorcycle yeah you tackle them off
the motorcycle on a motorcycle you're
not [ __ ] Lightspeed man clearly
you've never seen you jog no you would
knock them off with whatever you had
then you pin them down on their stomachs
rip the pants off then insert yourself
yes I feel like there's a word for that
insertion rape making love it's not rape
if you deserve it though
who you agree
you steal an old woman's purse you
deserve it Oh in that scenario yeah I
thought you meant like this guy's kind
of annoying
oh he's trying to get away no okay what
a sentence when the cop the deputy would
ever running into that truck that can't
be looked it looked like an action that
can't be real why do you say that I feel
like it'd be impossible to gonna have a
moving car like that and then run and
catch up to the truck I don't know man
that look pretty [ __ ] real when the
guy did it
and that's impressive now a lot of these
heroic moments man you could get so much
you know vagina the hose nice apron
Danny you should've been in sync you
still call to tank your boyfriend never
is like yeah you like it when I [ __ ]
your putain know what about pre-maggie
know what about I'm taking your flower
no well we would not be good in debt to
you and the woman saving someone from a
car I've always wanted to do that I've
always wanted a car to just jump like
driving to a river and I'm like look I
hope there's someone recording so I
could have a viral video on YouTube I
could perform CPR on you I'd like to
record that but what if I like I really
need it and I have the water and then I
like water into your mouth what you be
disturbed no that would just enhance the
experience really okay I'd like being
degraded oh especially that unconscious
body mm-hmm that's a rare experience
it's not rare well it's not rare to do
something to the unconscious body but
it's rare for the unconscious body to do
something to turn you on
yeah I get turned on by a lot of
unconscious bodies we get it that's why
you email me all those pictures of my
he looks so beautiful that was a heroic
moment it was her I saved you from
falling off the bed let's see guys
subscribe to top 5 unknowns they're a
fantastic channel if you're new to this
channel you can subscribe today become a
rat and danielle has an Instagram where
she is so pretty and you know like you
can think of whatever you want when
you're looking at her photos she
encourages that she wants you to think
of stuff self-expression yeah and I'm
not talking about masturbation
you know like riding a pup oh really
what's your Instagram no dantana oh my
god
the hell what I just very popular you've
so many messages Stephanie Stephanie
hooked up boom yeah really
mm-hmm is that because like she hooks up
for people she's a free spirit